he done and what are you willing to do
to foster and promote more cohesion and
unity among Latin American countries
there is a lot of talk a little action
Latin America is the region where there
are more summits presidents get together
five or six times every year but yet
there is no integration there is very
limited trade infrastructure is very
weak there is another road for example
between Colombia and Panama that's
difficult to explain what can I do well
in today's world latin america has to
strengthen its domestic market has to
make sure that its consolidated as it
has a larger domestic market so we need
to start building infrastructure we have
to stop talking we need to start
building roads electricity grid lines we
need to start making sure that that
these countries are more integrated
physically they wear and they are not
ready to develop a common market